straight after the final whistle DW
reporter Barbara basil joined us from a
bar in Zagreb and we asked her to
describe the atmosphere which turned out
to be a rather needless question
[Applause]
okay so that was these
this is a cool and rainy evening in
Zagreb so all the public viewing took
place inside in inside the many bars of
the city and people were sort of going
between Despair and help and back at
horse and back and forth so I don't need
to tell you what the mood is like you
just got a little taste there are
absolutely over the moon it was not
clear I mean Brazil was there it was the
one side they were really afraid of
that's what you could what gracious
trainer as like that said before if we
look at the Players we know we have to
be afraid of them but they really
thought it out and then they showed this
tremendous resilience that seems to be
this rains of the after creation of the
creation team and so people are
absolutely Overjoyed this is going to be
one hell of a party tonight